tell us a little bit that child 44 year
old 44 directors daniel espinosa it has
Gary Oldman in it Tom Hardy Noomi Rapace
and a lot more other actors
I just finished on that a few weeks back
and that was amazing
that's about a Russian Soviet killer
killing kids and they're just trying to
find out who done it and there's a big
story and a lot more involved with that
Bush your role in that Jack can't say as
well seen the contact sorry hey no
worries course it like working with Tom
and Gary and new me amazing amazing so
down-to-earth grounded talented people
yeah I can't wait to work with them
again what did you kind of learn working
with those guys when you were on set
just watching their acting techniques
and stuff like that because I've never
been trained it I watch a lot of actors
and just kind of still a lot of stuff
and yeah it was amazing today at Fright
Fest for a short film called breathe
aren't you tell us about that
brave is like a short horror film slash
drama with the director Toby Meekins
we're here today to have a watch it's
it's been put forward to the world
premiere of Fright Fest and yeah here
today we're just about going now just
about going yeah excited can't wait to
see on the big screen
and just people you go wonder the film
you've got as well coming up knock
Coppola it used to be called wreck it's
also with Jeff and Anthony and Harry
Lloyd out of Game of Thrones tell us a
little bit about that and your role in
that too yeah I've only got a small role
in that where I play like a guy who saw
was kind of these drugs and basically
the main guy in the main guy in it he
tries to find out who's selling these
drugs basically it's a good film a bit
mad there's so much it's kind of like a
futuristic film I can't say much more on
that into it comes we look forward to
for me you next Joe and the hooligan
factory vent that are a long way down
what's coming out Aaron Paul Pierce
Brosnan's in that and that's it really
you